- - Avez-vous l'impression
quque votre niveau d'anxiété
a a augmenté avec la pandémie?
- - Ah ça, je pense que c'est s.
OnOn s'en est pas sorti...
C'C'est anxiogène d déjà e en p.
- - Parce qu'on a pas la capacié
dede se projeter dans le futur,
dodonc tout ce qu'on est en tran
dede faire c'est à t très cocout
teterme, ça fait que ça
amamplifie l'anxiété.
- - Avec la pandémie,
l'l'anxiété est montée d'un cra.
SeSelon une nouvelle étude
pupubliée dans la revue
scscientifique "The Lancet",
lala COVID-19 a fait bondir les
trtroubles anxieux et dépressif.
DeDepuis mars 2020, ils ont
rerecensé 76 millions de cas
susupplémentaires de troubles
ananxieux et 53 millions
dede troubles dépressifs majeur.
UnUne hausse de plus de 26 %..
ROROSE-MARIE CHAREST, psychologe
- - 26-28 %, là, , c'est énormet
dede dépressions majeurs ici, l.
LaLa dépression majeure
c'c'est être e touché, êtree
inincapable de fonctionner,
êêtre e souffrant et ça, ça veut
didire qu'il y a énormément de
pepersonnes qui non seulement ot
étété frappées par la crise, mas
ilils n'ont probablement pas ce
ququi faut pour se faire traite.
- - Dernièrerement, plusieurs
pepersonnalités publiques ont
avavoué avoir vécu des épisodes
plplus difficiles. C'est le cas
dede Denis Coderre, qui a jonglé
avavec des idées noires après
sasa défaite électorale de 2017.
DEDENIS CODERRE, candidat
mamairie de Montréal
- - Le fait d'en parler,
sisi ça peut démontrer que peu
imimporte le travail qu'on fait,
quque on n'est pas seul.
- - Québec anticipe une
auaugmentation des demandes
d'd'aide à l la suite de ces sos
pupubliques, il se dit prêt
àà l les accueillir,
mamalglgré la liste d'attente.
LILIONEL CARMANT, ministre déléé
SaSanté et aux Services sociaux
- - Les listes d'attente
n'n'augmentent pas malgré
unune augmentation de la demand.
EtEt ce qu'on a réussi à faiaire
c'c'est vraiment faciliter
l'l'accès.s.
- - Selon les données les plus
rérécentes, plus de 20 000
pepersonnes étaient toujours
enen attente pour recevoir
dedes services en santé mentale.
UnUn nouveau programme implanté
dadans cinq régions du Québec
auaurait porté fruit.
- - On a eu entre août t 2019
etet août t 2021 une diminution
dede 53 % de nos listes d'atten.
OnOn déploie à t travers le Quéc
d'd'ici mars 2022. Moi,
j'j'ai très coconfiance qu'on va
cocontinuer à s'a'améliorer.
- - Québec a investi plus
dede 100 millions de dollars
dedepuis novembre dernier
popour améliorer les services
enen santé mentale. D'ailleurs,
d'd'autres annonces sont prévues
d'd'ici la fin de l'automne.
I Ici Marie Josée Paquette-Comu
R Radio-Canada, Montréa